Traduttore: TEDx Milano Translators
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Non vi parlerò di innovazione tecnologica,
o almeno come me la sto immaginando.
E prima di raccontarvi un po'
quello che sto facendo,
vi voglio raccontare una storia
che vi fa capire, anche,
che il tema della sostenibilità
è un tema che viene da lontano.
Il primo -
questo racconto che vi voglio narrare
riguarda una storia meravigliosa.
Marco Polo attraversa,
da Venezia fino alla Cina,
e quando arriva in Persia,
nel cuore della Persia,
quindi siamo tra l'Iraq e lran,
luogo di deserti, un caldo micidiale-
Quando arriva in un villaggio,
i persiani, in segno di benvenuto -
siamo nel 1472-73,
in segno di benvenuto
gli offrono un gelato al tamarindo.
Nel 1470 un gelato al tamarindo?
È una domanda a cui
bisogna darsi una risposta.
Come facevano a mangiare il gelato?
È per questo che poi
è importante parlare di architettura.
I persiani probabilmente
ci hanno messo secoli
a capire come funzionava
il meccanismo, no?
Siamo in un periodo
in cui l'energia non c'è.
Allora costruivano questo
edificio che voi vedete,
che è un grande muro esposto a sud.
Questo muro proteggeva una piccola,
chiamiamola piscina,
un piccolo avvallamento.
E davanti a questo muro
c'era una grande cupola
che era stata ottenuta
scavando una cisterna.
E i persiani cosa facevano?
Di notte,
depositavano uno strato sottile
d'acqua in questa piscina,
e siccome il muro ha protetto
tutto il giorno dal sole quell'area,
non aveva avuto nessun guadagno termico,
non si è mai scaldata.
Per effetto della calotta celeste,
che, come voi sapete
quando viaggiate in aereo,
il comandante dice, -
la temperatura esterna -55 gradi - ,
la calotta celeste è -55 gradi
e per effetto della radiazione celeste,
in un periodo storico
dove non c'era, ovviamente, inquinamento,
c'era trasparenza del cielo
e per effetto della radiazione celeste
questo strato di acqua ghiacciava.
E notte dopo notte,
i persiani toglievano,
rompevano questo ghiaccio
e lo mettevano in questa cisterna.
Durante l'estate, + 55 gradi esterni,
una cupola protegge
questo grande invaso di ghiaccio
attraverso un semplice
principio di ventilazione,
quindi le radiazioni del sole
che si trasformava in una temperatura
all'interno di questa cupola
veniva poi espulsa
attraverso un sistema
di ventilazione naturale.
Questa è una delle architetture -
poche, purtroppo - rimaste,
a causa della guerra che,
oltre ad essere un fatto negativo,
è anche una distruzione della cultura.
Questo esempio è un esempio importante,
perché i persiani,
nonostante il grande calore estivo,
si mangiavano un gelato,
durante l'estate, e lo offrivano.
Da noi, forse, a Roma
l'avrebbero chiamato una grattachecca,
che è ghiaccio triturato
insieme alle essenze.
Questo è un esempio
che per me è importante raccontarvi,
perché stiamo guardando
quello che succederà
nei prossimi 30, 40, 50 anni.
Ora, per darvi
una dimensione del problema,
e poi capirete perché
vi ho parlato di Marco Polo-
parlare di sostenibilità è importante,
perché quello che sta succedendo
non ha precedenti nella nostra storia.
Cioè, tanto per darvi dei numeri:
sulla terra sono state costruite, oggi,
145 miliardi di metri quadri,
che non so neanche io dirvi
quanto sono fisicamente.
Tanta roba, tanta roba.
Però il punto non è quello.
Il punto è che nei prossimi 15 anni,
costruiremo la metà di quello
che abbiamo da sempre costruito.
Questa è la dimensione del problema.
73 miliardi di metri quadri
sono più o meno un miliardo di alloggi.
Questo è quello che succederà,
e che sta piano piano succedendo
nei paesi che stanno crescendo.
Magari l'Italia ha un problema diverso,
però in altri paesi del mondo -
Allora, per poter fare quello,
cioè per costruire 75,
73 miliardi di metri quadrati,
abbiamo bisogno di cemento,
di vetro, di mattoni, di calce.
Abbiamo bisogno di portare l'acqua,
in qualche posto, abbiamo bisogno
di fare del raffrescamento,
come in queste immagini,
che vi fanno capire anche
la dimensione del consumo.
Non è che ci siamo affidati
un po' troppo alla tecnologia?
Perché poi la tecnologia -
e in questo caso
io parlo di quella edilizia,
non parlo della tecnologia
in senso più vasto -
La tecnologia negli edifici
è stata una grande conquista.
Perché, negli ultimi 50 anni,
abbiamo vissuto in edifici
che non avevamo più
nessun rapporto con il clima.
Era totalmente indifferente sapere
se fuori c'era caldo, c'era freddo.
Io avevo il mio condizionatore,
con il mio controllo termico.
Ecco, questa innovazione tecnologica
che è stata un po' come questi robot,
sono un po' un sogno dell'uomo:
fare qualcosa contro natura.
Però adesso quella natura
ci ha presentato un conto.
Avete voluto gli edifici tecnologici?
E adesso abbiamo una serie di problemi
che abbiamo sentito anche prima.
Che sono poi quelli
del cambiamento del clima,
condizioni di cambiamento locale.
Allora, forse, nel guardare anche
gli obiettivi dei prossimi anni,
noi ci dobbiamo porre delle questioni.
Ora, per darvi un altro dato semplice,
ogni settimana si spostano,
dalle campagne nelle città,
un milione e mezzo di persone.
Questa è la transumanza che sta avvenendo.
Anche su questo
varrebbe la pena di discutere,
perché questo grande fenomeno
delle megalopoli
è stato un grande sogno,
è anche una grande opportunità,
però ha avuto anche alcuni
piccoli effetti collaterali, no?
È per quello che, se avete avuto
occasione di vedere la Biennale,
parliamo proprio delle aree interne,
che cioè non sono città metropolitane
perché sono dei giacimenti culturali.
Che cosa sta succedendo?
Noi abbiamo davanti
una road map che è stata -
L'Europa ha disegnato uno scenario,
e questo scenario non ha più alternative,
la strada è questa.
È dal 1992, con Rio de Janeiro
che c'è ogni anno, da 21 anni,
una conferenza sul cambiamento del clima.
L'ultimo accordo, quello di Parigi,
quello diciamo più di successo,
è anche il risultato
di 20 anni di discussioni.
Ma perché è importante il tempo?
Perché qui il tema vero
non è solo il cambiamento del clima,
che quello tanto arriverà comunque,
che vogliamo o non vogliamo,
con tutti gli sforzi che faremo.
Il vero cambiamento, qui,
è il cambiamento culturale.
Noi dobbiamo entrare in un'altra era.
Non siamo più dentro l'era
dell'uso dei combustibili fossili.
Entriamo in un'altra era,
un'era ecologica.
In un'era ecologica, come qui-
Vedete, questa mappa ci dice che nel 2020,
nel 2030 avremo degli appuntamenti,
ma l'obiettivo qual è?
L'obiettivo è ridurre
le emissioni di gas serra.
E ancora, nonostante l'accordo di Parigi,
quest'anno gli indici
sono di crescita, e non di decrescita.
Ma allora il framework che cosa ci dice?
Io ve ne parlo-
Sembra che non sto parlando
di architettura, però è importante.
Perché il mondo costruito
contribuisce per il 70 percento
alle emissioni di CO2
dei consumi energetici.
Quindi abbiamo, assolutamente,
titolo per parlarne.
Qui ci chiedono:
di ridurre le emissioni di CO2;
a parte i numeri,
di fare del risparmio energetico;
e dall'altra parte
di consumare meno energia.
Ma com'è che facciamo a fare questo?
Perché il CO2 non si vede.
E in una società di immagine,
una cosa che non si vede non esiste.
Come facciamo a produrre
energie rinnovabili?
E come facciamo a consumarne di meno?
Allora, forse, ed è questo
che mi sembra il tema più interessante,
forse dobbiamo andare a pescare
proprio in quell'enorme
giacimento culturale
che è la nostra storia,
in cui si sono costruiti edifici
dove l'energia non c'era.
Come hanno fatto per 2000 anni
a fare edifici meravigliosi
dove l'energia non era
una delle componenti essenziali?
Questo mi fa pensare che il tema
dell'innovazione va un po', forse-
forse dovremmo un po' rivedere
che cos'è l'innovazione.
Se è soltanto una macchina,
se è soltanto un programma,
se è soltanto un computer.
O forse, nell'edilizia o nell'architettura
dobbiamo ritrovare una relazione
che io chiamo di empatia con l'ambiente.
Quindi ci sono degli esempi meravigliosi.
Adesso io non vi voglio tediare
con tante cose, però,
per secoli, gli uomini hanno creato,
come dire, una complicità con l'ambiente.
Hanno costruito - queste sono
delle torri del vento.
Prendono il vento predominante,
lo portano dentro le case,
raffrescano le case di notte
e di giorno ci sono dieci gradi di meno.
Ora è chiaro che noi
non vogliamo fare questo.
Questo è il passato,
io non sono un nostalgico,
né tantomeno ho quell'idea
che il passato è sempre meglio del futuro.
Io credo che il futuro sarà sempre meglio.
Però mi incuriosisce.
Mi incuriosiscono,
per esempio, i pakistani,
che fanno queste torri
con questa specie di catcher,
questo aquilone,
che raccoglie il vento,
lo incanala nelle case,
e riduce la domanda di temperatura.
Di notte, queste case sono più fresche,
e di giorno - fuori ci sono 50 gradi,
dentro ce ne sono 42.
Ci sono 7, 8 gradi di differenza.
Tutto questo mi fa pensare
che lì dentro, in questi edifici -
non li rifaremo sicuramente così,
però si nasconde una conoscenza.
Cioè sapevano, come si faceva.
Si sapeva come reagire.
Allora, se l'Europa mi sta dicendo,
e noi tutti stiamo lavorando
con questa idea,
che gli edifici del 2020,
cioè dopodomani,
devono essere a quasi energia zero,
e quel "quasi" dovrebbe essere fatto
con una fonte rinnovabile,
la prima cosa che mi viene in mente
è "mi vado a studiare i pakistani".
Mi vado a studiare quelli che con
l'energia hanno avuto questa complicità.
Poi noi viviamo in un mondo
dove abbiamo una opportunità
che non abbiamo mai avuto.
Che è quella, appunto, della tecnologia.
Loro non avevano neanche un computer,
ma i persiani, forse facendo tante prove,
avevano capito che a un certo momento
questo rapporto con l'ambiente
poteva essere molto vantaggioso.
Cioè quell'energia, che era fuori,
era qualcosa che poteva
essere utile all'uomo;
che non era contro l'uomo, ma era per lui.
Noi, questa cosa,
l'abbiamo totalmente persa.
Cioè abbiamo completamente perso
la capacità di dialogare con l'ambiente,
perché abbiamo avuto
un sogno meraviglioso.
Abbiamo detto: adesso,
con la tecnologia, con le macchine,
facciamo tutto quello che ci pare.
Figurati, quello che c'è fuori
non ci interessa.
Ecco, questa cosa qui non funziona più.
Mi piace pensare
che il futuro dell'innovazione
sia di fatto una cosa ibrida.
Forse c'è tecnologia,
ma c'è anche conoscenza,
c'è anche qualcosa che noi sapevamo fare.
Noi la sapevamo fare, questa cosa.
Un altro esempio meraviglioso.
Questa proprio è una storia da architetti.
Questo è un palazzo a Merhabad.
Invece che costruito sopra la terra,
è scavato sotto terra.
Ogni dieci metri che si scende,
si perde un grado.
E queste erano le case, e le piazze,
dove si rifugiavano gli indiani
quando fuori c'erano 60 gradi.
Ed erano anche dei luoghi
pubblici, questi.
Quindi era un edificio al contrario.
Era nella penombra.
la terra- come voi sapete,
quando voi scavate la terra,
dopo alcuni metri
la temperatura è costante,
intorno ai 16, 17 gradi.
Quindi se io - per quello c'è
un'architettura ipogea straordinaria:
quando io vado sottoterra,
qualunque sia la temperatura esterna,
io dentro sto a 18, 20 gradi.
La cosa bella di questo
edificio, se vi capita -
si chiama Stepwell, in India,
era venuto talmente bene,
questo edificio,
il Maharaja era così contento,
che ha uccisio i sei architetti
che ci avevano lavorato.
E fuori dall'ingresso di questo edificio
ci sono, in forma di onore, le sei tombe.
Come a dire: è talmente bello,
che non lo dovete più fare per nessuno.
Ecco, questi sono i rischi del mestiere.
(Risate)
Oggi -
(Applausi)
E qui torniamo anche
sul fatto della responsabilità.
Perché fare questo mestiere -
io dico sempre [che] gli architetti
sono delle persone molto pericolose,
perché possono far costruire
delle cose meravigliose
o possono lasciare degli incubi.
E di incubi ce ne sono tanti,
in giro per il mondo.
Questa è la Camera dello Scirocco,
dove i catanesi si rifugiavano
quando c'era lo scirocco.
E questa camera, a ventilazione naturale,
permetteva di stare sotto.
Ora vi faccio vedere
due cose semplici, per chiudere,
su che cos'è il rapporto con la natura.
Queste sono le dune d'Algeri,
e queste sono costruzioni di pietra
che si facevano per
raccogliere la temperatura,
e al cambio giorno-notte dell'umidità
intorno a queste pietre
si condensava l'acqua dell'umidità,
e si costruivano delle pozze
per poter dar da bere agli animali.
La forma è stata poi l'oggetto di questo.
Questo è un edificio
che stiamo facendo ad Algeri,
ed è il primo edificio
che affronta questo tema
della sostenibilità dei consumi,
in un paese che è il più grande
produttore di gas del mondo.
Questa è una palma, e una grotta di sale,
da cui è nato questo edificio,
che è in Ghana,
che abbiamo fatto
per un developer ghanese,
e che è diventato un landmark,
perché ha ricollegato
alcuni temi che erano perduti:
l'ombreggiamento,
la ventilazione naturale.
Tutti temi che hanno permesso
a questo edificio
di funzionare per la metà dell'anno
senza nessun condizionamento.
Soltanto attraverso un principio passivo.
Quindi mi piace pensare
che forse il futuro dei nostri edifici
non è più l'high-tech,
quell'edificio muscolare
pieno di impianti,
ma forse è una mediazione
tra conoscenza e innovazione.
E chiudo con questa immagine, un saluto.
Questo è un beduino con il suo cammello
che attraversa il deserto.
Vabbè.
Detto questo,
se io cambio il punto di vista,
e vi faccio vedere questo,
questo non è un beduino.
È un dottore che ha un cammello,
che sulla testa ha un'antenna GPS,
ha un pannello fotovoltaico
che produce energia,
che alimenta una batteria,
che alimenta un frigorifero
con le medicine.
Ecco: qui, in questa immagine
si nasconde un'idea
che non abbiamo ancora capito.
Che, forse, il futuro è questa capacità
di mettere insieme innovazione tecnologica
e conoscenza antica come il mondo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)